oui monsieur le sénateur Husson là aussi
je connais votre engagement sur le sujet
des sciences physiques je suis pas là
pour être inquiet je suis là pour être
déterminé et déterminer dans le
rétablissement des finances publiques
avec des décisions très structurantes
qui d'ailleurs ont été votées pour
certains par votre groupe dont je salue
l'esprit de responsabilité les premières
décisions structurantes ça a été la
réforme de l'assurance chômage et la
réforme des retraites que vous avez
votées et dont je rappelle que fiche
contrairement à ce que j'entends dire
trop souvent a saluer l'efficacité pour
le rétablissement des finances publiques
la deuxième décision très concrète ça va
être la sortie du bouclier tarifaire la
fin du gel sur les prix du gaz puisque
les prix du gaz sont revenus à la
normale et la sortie progressive du
plafonnement sur les prix de
l'électricité nous voulons que d'ici la
fin 2024 début 2025 nous soyons sortis
définitivement et totalement des
boucliers tarifaires qui étaient utiles
pour protéger nos compatriotes quand
c'était nécessaire mais qui ne sont plus
utiles dès lors que les prix reviennent
à la baisse j'espère que vous nous
soutien permet aussi dans cette décision
enfin troisième remarque la loi de
programmation des finances publiques une
fois encore j'en ai parlé à plusieurs
reprises avec le président de votre
groupe je reste ouvert à tout
amélioration qui permettra d'adopter
cette loi de programmation des finances
publiques et de graver dans le marbre de
cet engagement pourquoi c'est important
mais pas pour faire plaisir aux agences
de notation mais une fois encore pour
rétablir totalement et pleinement notre
indépendance et notre souveraineté
financière et tout simplement aussi
parce qu'en période d'augmentation des
taux d'intérêt laisser filer la dette
comme le propose certains c'est jeter
l'argent par les fenêtres un point de
taux d'intérêt supplémentaire c'est
horizon 2027 15 milliards d'euros de
charges supplémentaires sur la charge de
la dette c'est plus que le budget du
garde des sceaux je pense que le Garde
des Sceaux est surtout tous nos
compatriotes préfèrent qu'on dépense de
l'argent pour les policiers pour la
sécurité pour les gendarmes pour la
justice pour l'école pour l'hôpital pour
les services publics plutôt que pour le
service de la dette c'est pour cela que
vous pouvez compter monsieur le sénateur
sur ma détermination totale à rétablir
les finances publiques et accélérer nos
endettement
[Applaudissements]
monsieur rapporteur général
oui vous dites monsieur le ministre
déterminé si j'en juge par les six
années qui sont passées et le résultat
qui est celui qu'on constate aujourd'hui
au moins je fais un constat c'est que
vous avez singulièrement manqué des
dominations deuxième élément qui me
paraît inquiétant puisque je suis
également inquiet ce sont les chiffres
qui sont dans le programme de stabilité
que nous allons examiner ce soir que
nous avons mis à Bruxelles où je dois
vous dire que les dépenses par rapport à
la loi de programmation que nous avons
étudié à la fin de l'année en décembre
elles ont augmenté de 30 milliards
d'euros dérives supplémentaires alors
Monsieur le Ministre oui nous sommes
déterminés mais nous sommes déterminés
pour un temps de vérité et non pas pour
du camouflage parce que ce qui est en
train de se passer vous nous demandez de
travailler sur la loi de programmation
des finances publiques mais alors
pourquoi avez-vous continué à dépenser
de l'argent que nous n'avons pas qu'il
faut aller emprunter quand nous vous
avons proposé au mois de décembre des
pistes d'économie vous avez balayé d'un
verre de main ces regrettable donc je
vais vous dire comme je l'ai dit il y a
pas très longtemps monsieur le ministre
il faut vraiment se mettre au travail
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]